luego de tres meses prófugos Germán
Cáceres ex integrante de la Policía
Nacional que conmocionó la opinión
pública ecuatoriana por el crimen contra
su propia esposa y el modus en que actuó
fue identificado y detenido en el norte
de Colombia es el principal sospechoso
el femicidio de la ex abogada María
Belén Bernal de 34 años de edad Fue
capturado la noche de este 30 de
diciembre en una playa de Palomino Santa
Marta en Colombia para detenerlos se
requirió el seguimiento del cuerpo de
investigaciones de la Fiscalía de
Colombia la unidad de investigaciones
ejecutivos los Marshall y el bloque de
búsqueda del ejército colombiano junto a
la policía de Ecuador lo presidentes de
Ecuador Guillermo lasso y de Colombia
Gustavo Petro se comunicaron el día de
ayer para confirmar su detención Pero
quién era Germán Cáceres es una de las
personas más buscadas en el país andino
antiguo instructor de la Policía
Nacional y el principal sospechoso del
femicidio de María Belén Bernal a quien
se le vio por última vez dentro de la
escuela superior de la Policía Nacional
había abandonado el país luego de dar su
versión en la fiscalía lo que incluso
tan valió la estructura de la policía
Germán Cáceres y María invernal se
habían casado en octubre del año 2017 su
acento y la frase gracias ñaño Que
despedía a sus clientes trabajando en un
bar de la actual ex policía que fue
destituido junto a otros cuatro
funcionarios Colombia ha puesto a
disposición un avión para trasladar a
Cáceres hacia Ecuador el alto mando
militar de Ecuador ha confirmado que se
iniciarán los procedimientos para su
traslado al país andino Mientras tanto
la mamá de María valer Bernal demandó
que se ha puesto buen resguardo para que
este no vuelva a escapar o Cometa
suicidio para evadir el peso de la